all right well thank you being the last
speaker I decided that I well I should
my toe should be light on the technical
details I'm sure it's it's been a long
day and you you must be exhausted
well when I was removing technical
details I realized I removed a lot of
paralyzation issues as well but well
it's still about handling extremely
large craft so there should be something
interesting for you all right so I'll be
talking about I'm not telling anything
something you haven't heard you for
today but today I'll be talking about
settling and streaming style algorithms
and by these well these algorithms what
they do is they look at the only small
portion of your graph you have a metric
in mind and I want to compute this
metric but look at the only small
portion of your graph and I'll give you
an estimate and on top of this I'll also
give you an upper bound and lower bound
so I'm 99% confidence that the area's
well number is 0.5 plus minus 0.01 so
that's the kind of algorithms our we're
trying to design and by doing this well
you can complete general trends in your
graph so if something is very frequent
you can't count it but you cannot or
something is really big you can detect
it but if you're looking for a needle in
a haystack ball you cannot do sampling
or streaming algorithms and I'm not
sampling well it's not an alternative to
parallelization actually they get along
well each with each other because while
you're but if you're doing if you're
complete if you're doing something
efficiently while you're communicating
efficiently as well so it performs well
well they get along well unless your
contract akkad flops or something like
that I'm trying to be a computer of a
report joint flop flop numbers so this
is in terms of productivity
parallelization and sampling go well
with each other
so what I'll focus on for these patterns
Ernests well graphs and our focus on
counting triangles in graphs and what do
I care about graphs well if you get to
literature there are only two references
accounting graphs today and it is a
problem and people have used it in
different ways and when I talk about
browser I'll talk about triangles and
wages and which is I have two friends
for instance I form a batch me and my
two friends form a wedge and triangle if
my friends know each other are form a
closer to that Ridge and that forms a
triangle and people you said this word
used these metrics for different
purposes again where it's all mostly
friends of how often friends of friends
because become friends themselves and
the reason we got into this is we were
trying to build a model brach model well
we want to generate graphs you'll get
you'll get special give me a few
parameters I'll do a graph just like the
real graph and we were trying to figure
how to do this and something we observed
in most of the real grass was this
clustering coefficients and what you see
in these pluses I'm not only look at
this how often friends or friends become
friends but only a divided by decrease
of tortoises let's look at all the
degrees of for a degree 5 how often they
are trying wage is close and it's the
plot you see here and they always start
with extremely low high well for this
courtship process throw it around one
for other graph they don't start one but
it's very point four but they always
start to extreme very high and then they
decrease slowly and you cannot this is
not something you can you can explain by
the degree distribution so you look at
the same figures for a chunk look at
graphs so this is a distinguishing
factor and you want to I want to model
grass with it so I want to compete these
things efficiently and that's how I get
into this so a little bit more of the of
the definitions so when I say talk about
I'll say like clustering coefficient and
transitivity well they mean I mean they
they mean the same thing to me and we're
talking about the number of close
bridges the ratio of number of close
majors to no total number of pages again
how often friends or friends become
friends and if you look at another way
to look at this as it's three times the
number of triangles because each
triangle has three close wedges and so
if you want to computers think by
alright so this is an open wedge you see
there because E and G are not close
there's not an H from ing and here you
see a close
and if you want to compute this by using
enumeration while you look at all the
wages right you look at how often
they're closed and you could what we've
proposed is well this is about the core
idea okay if there is something it
repeats so many times I don't need to
look at each one
I'll just sample it and I'll get a good
idea about how many how the ratio or how
often these things are listened is
closed all right so let's conceptually
I'm let's make an index of all the wages
in the graph so we don't know neat about
this inner algorithm so we don't do that
explicitly I can generate lkf it's open
I'm also putting a mark next to it sure
the next one is open and this one is
closed and I'll keep doing this and so
let's define a number so let's say I
have this index now for all the weight
of edges in the graph and some are
marked as close our mark is open and
let's define an experiment now so I flip
a coin I'll choose one of these wedges
and I'll see I'll get one if it's close
and I get zero if it's not so it's this
is a random variable and it's
expectation of X is exactly the treat
names
it's the transitivity how often these
things are closed this thing is the
wedges are closed so if I know that I
can design an algorithm based on this so
it's instead of looking at one I can
keep repeating pick another one pick
another one randomly and see if this
thing is converging the critical thing
is well for a randomized algorithm mean
matching the expectation that's the
least you can do well that's if you're
not your expected value is not matching
the true value you're in the apparel
anyway but what makes it a randomized
our current better is well it's
concentration if I run this experiment
if you can give me a bound on trust me
this is close enough so that's the ball
you have to be provide their confidence
ponds and how many samples do I need to
get confident well if you look at the
chair of huffing bounds it tells you
exactly how many units and this is in
this figure epsilon is the error how
much error I can't tolerate clustering
coefficient let's say I don't want to be
off more than 0.01 you specify that and
Delta there is that's my confidence but
my confidence one minus Delta let's say
99% confident that your error is less
than this so that's you only specify how
much error you can tolerate and what
confidence you want and confidence
easily comes easy it's a logarithmic
term and then I can tell you how many
samples you need for instance if you
want the error to be less than 1% and
you want to be extremely confident we
only need 38,000 samples the best part
of this is well what is not in this
video and that's there's nothing
specific about the graph about the size
of the graph you can volume it graph it
million vertices or million edges
I'll need 30k 38,000 samples make it
this sort of a meal and make it a
billion I'll still need the same number
of samples so that's the number at the
time to sample average increases but the
number of samples you need does not so
it's the best part of it and also when I
present this people get stuck on if hey
if how do you step out generate all the
wages if you generate all the wages you
already killed yourself so you don't
have to do that so you when you're
sampling the wages you can do it in the
air during the algorithm so you know how
many edges each vertex generates that's
its degree choose two and I can pick one
vertex randomly based on the based on
its degree and then I choose two of its
neighbors randomly and that gives me
away which and this is the algorithm and
the implement this algorithm so if
there's a lot of graphs mostly from the
snap data set and you see the error well
the true number the exact number - well
how old absolutely of the difference
between what's estimated and what's the
two numbers it's always secret and this
is your you see the speed ups here or
over full enumeration that's extremely
fast because well we don't do much work
we just use a fixed number of samples
and I in the first slide I was talking
about clustering coefficients by degree
so you can't compete those things as
well and you can compete other final
levels to this it's 36 full on the same
data and I'm not getting to that but
well they think works and prim practice
as well and at the same time I give you
of guarantees about more given the
number of samples how much it can be all
right so so far well the algorithm is
good but what I was assuming that well
conveniently the whole graph fits into
the memory so I can sample things and I
can see if these things are closed or
not so what do I do for larger graphs
and so these are a few of the graph so
I'm presenting the number of vertices
edges wedges and triangles on the
logarithmic scale so this it does not
fit into any single computer and how do
I do
completely a predicted number of
computed statistics or is much larger
graphs
well there and Hadoop implementation and
the implementation is not really
specific it's not explaining anything
specific to Hadoop but we implemented on
Hadoop because the atera says well data
is already on the Hadoop and we had
implemented and you can say take same
ideas and use any other paralyzation to
change the MPI or GraphLab which Joe was
talking about today and the same
principles of the algorithm while
fine-tuning will be different but same
principle of the algorithm will apply so
the key to success is that well if I'm
doing sampling I do come to about if I
do work efficiently I'm doing a
communication efficiently as well I'm
doing very little work and so this is
the experimental setting and the
implemented over time I will just at
this part I'm waving my hands I promise
you not to do too much of the technical
detail but well you can find the paper
on archive or as you can from fire if
you're really interested you can ask me
how we implemented this and this is well
we're looking at computing the
clustering coefficients by degree for
the plots and we use logarithmic means
200 some 2,000 samples per beam and you
see it runtimes here and if the graph
gets larger ball you get much more
benefit before larger graphs so
different colors of course more
different phases of the algorithm the
big one the first phase is computing the
degree distribution you're computing the
degree of each vertex and that's what
takes most of the time so
and on the upper side you see a plot for
run times versus the number of edges in
the graph
well our Helius edges because a degree
distribution competing degree
most of the time I want too much put too
much weight on the exact numbers but
generally this scaling is is linear all
right so this was the second part of the
talk and I serve it well how to do
computer a triangle it's tragic measures
efficiently on a single processor and
now if I have the data is too big to put
on a single processor I didn't explain
you how we did it but it's doable and if
by using these resources and the next
thing is what if I have the data
streaming and this is for many of the
applications we are interested in data
keeps flowing so it's not like you want
to store the whole data to disk first
purposes the data later that to make a
simple simple graph out of it and then
you run your behave favorite algorithms
so if you don't have time for that the
data keeps coming and in real-time or
near real-time you want to be able to
compute some statistics statistics about
your data and think about the cyber of
cyber security the data communications
keep coming and when you do the analysis
it may be already too late so for
station awareness I want to do these
things
a real real-time and so that's the next
step for forestock and well you can use
streaming algorithms to technique to
well analyze it in real time or you can
use the same techniques to analyze data
with using small memory even if you
don't in real time it's not an issue so
then when I say streaming the model I
have in mind is the data keeps coming
and each each step I have a new data
item and I'm the monitor there so I
along with me I have a small storage I
cannot store terabytes of data or on the
only storage each each time I'm keeping
me some local data structures each for
each data item I do whatever I want or I
have take my data structure so I cannot
take my predictions but when I'm done it
is the data it's gone
so I cannot go back and take a look at
the same data again so I'm making a
single pass and I can about the process
to do the updates all the updates in
real time and again while it's the same
thing with streaming you cannot so all
the problems doing
but there are problems you can't you can
solve all right so Beulah apply the same
ideas rich sampling but it's a much
harder problem now so the the one of the
components well in the Alberta maintains
three data structures one is the edge
reservoir the second one is the weight
reservoir and third one is a binary
binary array it keeps track of if the
wedges are closed or not the way y'all
Girton works is is I maintain a random
set of edges and think about the graph
formed by those random set of edges it's
sufficiently large what is sufficient I
don't I'm not going now and now yet so
these grow edges form bridges
so it's a graph so eventually solved two
of two edges will be adjacent to the
same vertex and if you form a wedge and
then that wedge graduates and gets to
next step well it by put it on the
reservoir again I'll have a lot of
ridges I'll maintain a random sample of
the wedges it's not unlike a not keep
track all the way just because our
buildings of the edges anyway and the
next step is I put on a reservoir and
then for each edge coming does it close
any of two wedges so I check that and
which if any of the wedges are close I
put a one if it's not close I put a zero
and in the end so there is a still a
problem
for competing clustering coefficient I
complete three times the ratio of close
bridges so the multiplication by three
that's the unboxing factor I'll come
back to that and so it's just hand wave
a lot of hand waving but well I want the
edge reservoir to be big enough but how
big is big enough so here the birthday
paradox comes to the rescue
what it says is actually a which is two
edge of saving the same birthday so
these edges have evolved a to birthdays
but small never mind that's details
nothing yet fixed on that so if two
burger edges collide by one vertex table
form of edge and birthday paradox what
it tells me is if I should choose
scurried of and edges with extremely
high probability I will form a wrench
so I only need so that gives me guidance
on how big the edge razor or would be
and if I want even more I'll multiply
that size by K I my razor is always K
times bigger I'll generate K square more
widgets so put 1 you get to be 2 back so
it's you it's more K square 50 of
pay back so this is good so I can design
two algorithms based on that again
everything is based on birthday paradox
whenever we have we're in trouble you
get back to the birthday paradox and use
something to quantify things the Eichler
idealized algorithm is for each rich i
have individualized your it's personal
wage raised edge reservoir and i it's
all of its all of them are size of
square root of n and if you perform a
bridge and i check it check if it's
close or not so that's the idealized
algorithm and we can prove theorems well
we can do concentration bounds on these
things so that's all good but it needs a
lot of storage each wedge needs this
whole storage what we do is let's
increase the size of this edge reserve a
little bit and we'll then we'll get
jacked a lot of wedges so that's what we
do the downside is now my samples for
wages are correlated because they're
coming from the same sample edge set but
in practice we generate so many wedges
that whatever fits into that reg
reservoir it's only very small and
practically these are not we don't see
any any problems in practice again so
this is how you start with theory and
then engineer your theory to get a
practical algorithm and it were it was
very effective in practice and here are
my numbers
whoa I'm going much faster than I
thought all right so there's one more
thing on it it takes place so I I said
well we I want to multiply the well
cluttering the ratio of closed-closed
wages by 3 and why do I do that if I was
doing rate sampling the initial version
so let's think about the triangle at the
top I have ages 1 2 3 and they you see
they come in that order 1 and then 2 and
then 3 and if I mean great sampling pick
any of those edges and I can see that
I can detect that a well that which to
be closed but if I'm doing streaming
let's say I pick one and two I'm
starting oh I suck I pick one or two and
I looking for the h3 when it comes I'll
mark it as close yes I can detect that
but if I pick one and three all right so
I'm waiting for - but - it's already
gone it's in the past so I will not
leave even though it's close I'll not be
able to detect it and it's saying about
two and three
so for each triangle you can own biases
because we're each triangle there will
be only one wedge that's future close
that's close by an edge that will arrive
later so the probability that I will
pick that rich among the three wedges is
one-third and that's why I multiply the
closest in the ratio by three and this
is how you unbiased for the streaming
nature of the problem and here are some
results so this is for a lot of
processes about we're looking at the
clustering coefficients they're always
close and for a few of them there is
some difference it's not as close as we
what you saw it weight sampling but you
know it's a this is a much harder
problem and in practice we also looked
at how much deviation we have and it's
always close by so it's not like so in
these are not berries hand-picked cases
you run it and you don't get it a Eckerd
stall most of the time and the best part
is that well for this these experiments
are used V is only twenty thousand H
edges for the H pool and twenty thousand
wages for the vegetable and first orchid
has 200 million edges and I can't count
the number of triangles just by using
just kilobytes of memory and there is
extra benefit in thousand if you go to
thirty thousand it gets a little better
but after a while it just forty thousand
just bring on the whole universe so I
can count to triangle so it's the graph
can be as large as I want once you reach
these 44,000 wedges it's extremely
memory efficient and you can forest
stream you can monitor these things in
real time using very limited
and just for an experiment we did this
is for the citations graph we did the
same thing and the analysis for the full
enumeration force versus well you see
two runs here a counting number of
triangles in real time and updating our
data structures and we can create
attract these numbers in time all right
so this is I'm not giving to dig into
details of this too much but I talked
about streaming but whenever you have
streaming you also need a face of
repeated edges the streams don't come as
unique edges and they come as repeated
edges and we always make a community
assumption that before we start working
on the graph they remove all the
superior edges really removal you can do
a lot of stuff and then start start
applying algorithms it's a fair
assumption it doesn't make too much time
it's well if the problems are just do
that to pre-process your data but when
you're working with a stream you cannot
do this I mean it's the edges keep
coming on you don't know how if you've
seen it before or not so we extended the
same idea for these multi profs
and the trick is using a randomized
session for instead of flipping a random
coin for each edge are fitted to a
randomized sexualized function once I
set the seat for the hash function each
edge no matter when I see it will get to
map to the same hash value and if I want
to pick the first instance all of one
edge I'll take the license instance as
well so it doesn't make it it make a
difference so that's good for detecting
multiple edges but there's also the
problem with on biasing for instance if
I see a DBA a BBB and CCC this is
smaller corresponds to 1 to 3 edges
example or I can it makes a difference
if I see the same sequence as ABC ABC
because in the previous case if I pick
the wedge B and C for the first sequence
I'll not be able to detect that it's
closed for the other sequence
I will detect that it's closed actually
that is a problem here because my own
biasing will not work anymore so I'll
have a technique for the
it's sort of the future clothes we were
looking at lost future clothes instead
of on the East Coast variable these
sometimes reset the variable even if it
detector is one return to zero for
certain cases so I will not explain it
here but we can unbias it and we have
the version for I think it should be on
archive maybe it's on our kind now but
if it's not it will be soon maybe
tomorrow so you can see the algorithm
there and we were able to analyze
extremely large dataset and one thing we
did one thing what nice was bbl/d we
have worked with a row of data it's sort
of turning into a graph we just looked
at the row of data the number of names
of the authors and then we analyzing the
clustering coefficient for that and we
were extremely close in the analysis and
Bobby Jarrett some artificial datasets
and we always get good numbers as well
all right so to conclude so what I
talked about was using sampling and
streaming algorithms for the analyzed a
analyze data especially really very
strict we were focused on just traffic
measures and graphs but most of
techniques will apply to higher dated
search we'll come back to that and I
start with talking about the algorithm
this is the first version of the
algorithm that's on a single machine and
then all data gets bigger while sampling
we always talk about larger data and if
the data is your data is so large how
does it fit into a single process right
so we had a version for Hadoop
implementation for the distributed case
and then in the last part while we
extend this to the streaming case I see
the data once and I cannot see come back
to it again and well in general so you
can see these papers are mostly ordered
there online but in before that our
sampling in general it's a big part of
well large-scale data analysis of all of
these data as I said they're so large
that we have to use sampling we always
talk about yes data gets larger and
behaved will have increased
computational resources but the
increasing competition resources are
done they can keep up with the increase
in data sizes so we even will need to
use these sampling techniques as
much as possible if these would localize
the data or detects something is
abnormal and every confidence months
they're critical especially if you want
to for for practical problems for real
applications well I don't know if you
thought about but you can literally
offend people to by proposing their
proposal using sampling on their data
you say hey I we can use sampling - it's
all your problem efficiently what
material you're sampling you're not
looking half of my data but if you give
a confident if you tell said tell them
hey I'll give you conference pounds and
all the bounds they're more eager to it
to attract your methods and for John
here I think this is for when we talk
about graph journals how we do is
sampling on these graphs how do you
something kind of algorithms I think
that we should keep that in mind as well
and next steps these survey triangles
but nothing white rabbit triangles and
if you look at larger patterns and I
would to meet it's a two-way so what can
I count and what's the implication what
I what is tell me about the pool graph
for triangles we have an idea what it
means Molly if I look at these
clustering coefficients and the degree
distribution all have an idea about the
food graph for larger patterns I think
we start to understand what they mean
and we are currently working on
algorithms to count these things it's
not fiber Bryant metrics its finer
grained matter metrics it should be and
of just the number of triangles or the
degree based clustering coefficients
they're not sufficient so if you want to
do more and people always start asking
questions how about saying
compute this and that so we have to
adjust to two or more finer grained
metrics in this graph step and one last
thing is for now I'm looking at the
whole the importance of the first edge
and that last edge is the same but
that's what's by design but at the same
time if you're literally if you have
time in your graph that I send an email
two years ago to somebody it's not the
same thing as I sent an email five
minutes ago so we have to find something
to able to for these metrics generalize
the metrics for these analysis to
include time
and some of the ages should age and you
need to define first nice models for the
handle these things and mostly these
models I think the it will be much
easier to generalize the algorithms or
these new methods and that I'll stop and
take your questions